[Música]
con las botas el lazo y el sombrero
maurice white es todo un cowboy pero
como es negro no encaja en el
estereotipo de cowboy estadounidense sin
embargo eso es exactamente lo que es un
cowboy que trabaja en un rancho en
colorado
una carrera al aire libre que no se daba
por sentada cuando era niño en los años
una guarda para cuando era niño todas
las películas que veíamos eran westerns
mis héroes siempre han sido cowboys pero
yo sólo veía tipos blancos cabalgando y
me dije que yo iba a ser el tipo negro
que lo hiciera
como se explica en este museo poco
conocido en tempe colorado casi un
tercio de los cowboys durante la
conquista del lejano oeste eran negros
la mayoría eran esclavos liberados que
eligieron el duro trabajo de regar
ganado a su vez símbolo de libertad sin
embargo la historia borró casi por
completo esta realidad
los niños sólo veían cowboys blancos así
que nunca pensaron en un cowboy de james
que inventó el salto de hollywood
montando a caballo salta de lado toca el
suelo y vuelve a saltar a la silla
de salto está en todas las películas de
vaqueros pero nadie sabe que ese hombre
ese hombre de ahí es quien se lo inventó
[Música]
son muy necesitan
porque en el país de jonway hollywood
también contribuyó a borrar la imagen
del campo negro ya en los años treinta
había huertas de color como se les
llamaba entonces pero eran producciones
de bajo presupuesto que sólo se
proyectaban en los cines negros de los
eeuu segregados
en los años 50 y 60 durante el apogeo de
la segregación y del movimiento por los
derechos civiles los ejecutivos de las
cadenas y los directivos de los estudios
de cine no tuvieron el coraje de poner a
un hombre negro sobre un caballo y
convertirlo en héroe mientras que el
resto del país se estaban desgarrando
debido a la raza probablemente el
western negro por excelencia
eeuu está redescubriendo sus cowboys
negros parte gracias a la ola que
sacudió al país tras la muerte de georg
floyd de texas a california jinetes
negros cabalgaron en las demostraciones
exhibiendo que los caballos con un
símbolo de poder y conquista no son
terreno de los blancos
randy xavi dirigió las marchas en los
ángeles
los caballos siempre han estado en la
línea de frente de todas las luchas y
nosotros estamos luchando por una buena
causa por la paz así que para nosotros
era importante estar a caballo
simbolizando eso los caballos
representan la paz representan el amor y
representan el medio ambiente y la
naturaleza y esos son los valores que
nos guían
[Música]
[Aplausos]
actualmente una generación más joven de
afroamericanos está redescubriendo la
herencia de los cowboys negros con sólo
12 años habana roberts ya ha ganado
títulos de campeonatos de rodeo
me pongo ahí afuera para asegurarme de
ser un modelo a seguir para los jóvenes
afroamericanos solo quiero que sepan que
nadie nadie puede menospreciar los nadie
puede decirles no puedes hacer esto no
puedes hacer aquello
el modelo a seguir de sábana de charles
sampson en esa historia en 1982 cuando
se convierte en el primer afroamericano
en ganar el campeonato muy grande rodeo
un deporte emblemático en eeuu
[Música]
bueno
una vez que eeuu arregle su problema de
racismo y entienda que estamos en la
tierra de la libertad que somos iguales
entonces la raza no será una diferencia
nosotros estamos trabajando en eso como
estadounidenses
[Música]
en campos que van desde la política
hasta la ciencia es el eeuu blanco el
que ha escrito la historia del país hoy
los campos negros quieren reconquistar
el oeste